au lamentin les services de météorologie
ont bien sûr l'oeil sur le ciel depuis
décembre dernier très peu de pluie ont
été enregistrés cela continue le carême
la saison sèche est bel et bien présente
voilà la courbe de cette année là
2018-2019 foyer on est à la limite de la
sécheresse a un petit peu en dessous des
normales mais on est loin par exemple
d'un carême de 2010 ou d'un carême de
2003 d'envoyer on n'est pas dans une
situation dramatique mais pour autant il
faut quand même être vision pourquoi
parce que on a un phénomène el niño sur
le pacifique alors c'est pas un gros el
niño non plus à un niveau modéré qui est
un petit peu stable mais en général un
phénomène el niño ça veut dire un carême
un peu plus sec que la norme
quelques nuages aujourd'hui mais très
peu de pluie cette rivière par exemple
n'a pas son débit habituel
nous sommes quartier perriot lauf en
soient ici les agriculteurs font d'ores
et déjà intentions pour les mois à venir
il faut préparer le carnaval à l'avancé
bon là j'ai commencé les labos pour
pouvoir planter six à des restrictions
d'eau bon il faut qu'il faut doit
diminuer sous la production pour avoir
une meilleure production c'est pas la
peine d'avoir des gones surface et puis
ne pas pouvoir young le carême une
saison sèche qui s'achève entre mai et
juin pour laisser place à la saison
cyclonique